it doesn't seem to matter which corner
of the streaming world you came up in
whether you're into esports addicted to
among us or entranced by asmr you can't
not have a special place in your heart
for tim the tapman
oh my god there's another two down
[Applause]
knock knock knock knock that's the guy
who knocked you despite being worth
millions of dollars and one of the
biggest names in gaming he remains as
wholesome authentic and good-natured as
when he embarked on his streaming
journey a decade ago oh man
dude when i met up with tim
tim was like we were talking about our
houses and typically so she buy it and
cash was like tim i don't play warzone i
don't got it like that
and god is it fun to watch him mauled
i'm restricted for an hour
[Music]
i had the afk last game because my
son is potty training
and he started potty and then he got off
and he ran and he was still so alexis
was like it all over so she's like help
so i went out there and it was just like
a war zone man i just i had no idea what
was going on there was everywhere my son
was naked running around and in the
moment i had to prioritize
i scared my son dude
bro hang on
come on
whether he's squatting up with titans or
kicking it with his old counter strike
buddies you can always trust that tim
will be
well
tim i know i don't know how many viewers
are across the board do we have right
now
i don't even know man probably i
probably like what 500.
[Music]
brother you i mean that's like all a
mixer right
dude tyler's so mad right now because at
the end of the day
that's what people love about tim
the fact that despite achieving massive
success and enjoying all the perks of
someone who's too big for the rest of us
he's anything but
no matter who he's with he's the same
old tim he always was yeah
but watch this this guy peeks window the
same spot every single time watch
[Music]
but that doesn't mean there isn't depth
to the guy so today we're gonna take a
deep dive and figure out who is tim the
tatman really how did vaping bring his
competitive cs go career to a halt and
why does he take his anger out on a
penguin named kevin i'm just kidding
kevin i'm not going to hit you for a top
d all right i'm not mad that that i'm
not that much of a sellout mother shut
up kevin made you look
okay so before we commence our
expedition i kindly request that you
subscribe to the channel turn on
notifications and if you enjoy the video
leave a like and listen don't do it just
for me maybe do it for kevin he seems
like he could use a little bit of love
alright so let's inspect the waters
surrounding tim's bulbous iceberg
the tatman
okay so the first thing we're going to
talk about is quite literally the most
surface level thing about timothy john
vitar his tattoos tatted out to the
nines tim's trademark affinity for
inking himself head to toe has given
rise to a body of art that celebrates
his unashamed weeb dumb it's renji yomo
he he is starting at like right beneath
my ball sack and going down to my knee
he crushed it
it looks amazing so it's like the other
side is majin g to that side captain
levi he got his first tattoo a crown of
thorns on his arm at the age of 18 and
his alias was soon to follow and when i
was in college
um
one of my professors
i had my right arm done that's it and
one of my professors goes it was roll
roll call for the first day
and um
so they're going through all the names
like john karen blah blah blah and then
they get to meet tim
and i raised my hand i tattooed her arm
right i raised my tattoo arm naturally i
showed off dude
yeah and he goes
tim the tatman
and i was like huh that's a pretty
catchy name at this point i'd never done
youtube or anything but i decided in
that moment i was like if i ever try and
do youtube or anything i'm gonna be tim
the tap man
it makes sense why he'd want to look the
part of a tough guy obviously because
way back before he was this giggly goofy
teddy bear of a man tim was
something else
career crossroads
that's right back when tim kicked off
his streaming journey in 2012 he was
only doing it as a side gig back then
tim split his time between being a
college student and working full time as
a social worker but he dreamed of
something more it has been a dream and a
goal of mine to be able to do
this full-time when i say this i mean
stream i mean youtube i mean
hanging out with people in the gaming
world and having that be my career
thanks to his commitment to the grind by
2014 tim's twitch channel was doing well
enough that he was able to go full time
as a content creator within two years
tim had graduated from college and was
beginning to make a name for himself in
what might just be the last shooter
you'd ever expect
ow
[Laughter]
the global elite
way back before tim was one of the
biggest faces in battle royale's he
actually belonged to that esteemed group
of elegant elitists known as
counter-strikers this is tim we're
talking about so of course he brought
his usual flair
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's because more often than not tim
wasn't loading into rounds for a long
time but for a good time ready for this
chat i had one beer are you ready for
this god plan about to pull out
let me get a turkey
here he comes
now listen if you need practice for
having sex with your cousin just get
yourself a bagel put a little cream
cheese in there warm it up not slack
that'll last you about five seconds
[Applause]
of course tim's blunders are hilarious
but credit where it's due he did
actually have his moments there's two
eleven three advanced
[Music]
rip
in fact there was a time when mr tatman
was actually a member of the global
elite and that's something no one will
be able to take away from him
good job give me globally
yes
i'm never playing this game ever again
one thing that was taken away from him
though was his chance at a pro career
but to hear more about that we need to
go a little
deeper
pros don't vape
back in 2016 there was a time that tim
was so sweaty about cs go that he was
competing in actual tournaments and that
was helping bolster his stream's
popularity when we were playing those
tournaments i'd probably have my peak
viewership is probably 10 to 12k which i
know right now a lot of you are probably
like oh dude dead stream 10 000 viewers
whatever because you know chat's stupid
but dude back in the day for me that was
huge midway through the year tim joined
up for fun esea stack known as umps and
friends alongside phlom and emong and
with that choice any chance to call
himself a professional player was
squandered except he didn't squander it
dizzy did now for those who don't know
who dizzy is he's a super cracked
competitor and content creator who rose
to prominence in 2019 for being one of
the first truly talented terrors to try
their hands at apex legends anyway
before his apex centric glow up dizzy
was actually an ultra talented 15 year
old counter-strike phenom with a knack
for clicking heads recognizing this umps
and friends recruited dizzy for an esea
playoff match that they needed to win to
have a shot at pro league but
unfortunately for umps their newest
recruit let them down and he got
grounded
for vaping and we couldn't play
because he got grounded
a good parent dizzy i'm never gonna i'm
never gonna forget that i'll take that
to my grave whether vaping was the
actual reason dizzy got grounded remains
a mystery but to this day the meme
stands and dizzy will never ever live it
down
i always talk about dizzy
i always do
and i could have been pro and um
i uh
i always give them [__]
tim damage
over the years tim has developed such an
uncanny ability to well
fall off of [__] that his community of
fans has coined the term
tim damage
i know this is a shocker but i felt oh
my god
at least i killed myself no one gets to
kill me but me
trying to do it
above me
yep yep opposite side yeah i'm coming
i'm coming
dude his teammates snipe me out of the
air dude buy me back
it literally doesn't matter which game
he's playing if there is an elevated
surface from which tim can tumble
he's going down
the ultimate though is when tim's
in-game antics have caused him to suffer
real-life tim damage
push block harry push
parry push block parry push puck
[Music]
naturally the internet took the ball
and ran with it do you know how many
tweets i've seen or tick tocks of me
i got tsunamis i got explosions everyone
is just turning me hurting my back
into a meme okay
hey ron
oh my god
did you feel that chris
holy
and at some point tim's ordeal somehow
made its way into popular culture
i kid you now i went on a date last
night with a girl from tinder never
talked to her about twitch or gaming she
drunkenly tripped when i helped her up
she called it tim damage all right all
right all right what two parts
d if you're watching again
that's actually hilarious
all right we've learned some strange
things but i'm starting to sense shame
at this level
the fall guy
okay so tim has always had this
reputation of getting a little heated on
his streams i'm an emotional butterfly
you gotta let me blossom the butterflies
blossom that's just a flower i'm getting
distracted here but i think it's fair to
say that no title has ever sent him over
the edge quite like the surprise smash
hit of summer 2020
fall guys
[Music]
[Applause]
now as i'm sure you know everyone who
was anyone was obsessed with fall guys
for a solid two weeks
so what was it about tim's plight that
made it so noteworthy
well to put it simply the game he hated
him nope not going that way not going
that way
not safe
okay pickle get your hands off me
uh who just oh he got knocked off
knocked off who got knocked off tim did
you get knocked off this kid thank you
look me in the eyes when you're trying
to greet me little
[__]
back me out i'm not playing this one
back me out and it wasn't just that tim
couldn't buy a win
he couldn't even buy a qualification
[Music]
struggle became so real that at some
point both the official fall guy's
twitter account and the internet at
large began to roast him because of it
he even entered into a bet with formula
one driver lando norris as to who could
win first and he
lost
[Music]
this game is 90 map knowledge dude it's
like counter strike literally all
everyone wanted was for tim to just have
one single win to his name
it was
it was getting a little too sad to watch
starting platform when the first
[__]
damn this is just rng literally you got
balls flying everywhere dude it's stupid
and then on the 19th of august with
hundreds of thousands of viewers tuned
in
tim finally broke the curse
this is you one-on-one tim
timmy
[Music]
give me the crown
the bottom frag
if you spend any time watching tim
stream then you already know his
performances can at times be
questionable
matt i'm just looking on your roof to
make sure they don't get above you here
i have one rocket and one clip of ar
wait wait hold on matt don't go yet
wait
did you just assassinate him the reality
is that even though he's a lot better at
video games than his viewers give him
credit for tim has been known to
regularly bottom frag and it's not lost
on him
guys i may be one in ten i just want you
to know something that i am really gonna
bounce back here i'm really feeling it
so don't you worry absolutely
suffice it to say this could sometimes
give way to a little bit of teasing
clean yep there it is tim you are
trash and you get carried by everybody i
don't get carried by anyone bro what
eventually dawned on tim though was that
being well acquainted with the bottom of
the scoreboard actually made him more
relatable to his viewers in a meaningful
way i saw this on tick tock the other
day someone made a video for me they go
this is for tim the tatman and um
and it was actually a heartfelt message
from this guy and he goes tim
he goes i'm the worst in my group and
they all pick on him
you know and and he's like how do you
deal with it because i'm arguably i am
the worst in my friend group right when
i play with a lot of these guys it kind
of dawned on me that a lot of people are
in the same boat that i am um
and listen man if this guy sees this
tick-tock or if someone makes this tick
tock and i saw his message and his
question listen at the end of the day
you're more valuable than a
number okay from then on tim decided to
lean into a source of embarrassment and
turn it into a force of empowerment i
want you to know something you're at the
bottom of the leaderboard because you're
the anchor and you're the rock for that
team
you're the person that someone can yell
at because god knows there is a ton of
freedom in not being cracked i i've said
it before and i'm actually gonna say it
again i'm glad that i'm not really good
at games
because if i was sim and i had to defend
my ability
that'd be exhausting i'm glad no one
thinks tim's aimbotting right there's no
there's no there's reddit posts oh dude
tim the tatman's hacking dude right oh
check out this clip here's tim's aimbot
all right guys this is it the bottom
wait
is that what i think it is
kevin
if you've tuned into tim's stream over
the years no matter which setup he's
running he's always had this sweet
stubby little friend sitting right
beside him
all right kevin it's your show this is
the content that we've come to here all
right
i'll just be here
that kid's is kevin a plush penguin that
tim was gifted by a fan this cute little
guy has stood by tim's side through
thick thin and an endless barrage of
thumps throws and throttles
what
yay are you kidding me
because whether something goes right
goes wrong or just goes
tim will take it upon himself to beat
the ever living crap out of kevin
one
second
one second one the only one
second kevin in fact kevin has undergone
such a steady flow of abuse over the
years that he's inspired not only
feelings of sympathy within tim's
audience but a sense of social justice
look at this
look at look at that that's your hashtag
save kevin there's the first one to come
right out today still kevin's own
greatness remains unassailable he's a
living legend to this day he continues
to stand as the pillar and mascot on
which tim's tumultuous stream rests and
if beating the absolute stuffing out of
kevin isn't bad enough tim adds insult
to injury by exploiting him for
financial gain as well 85 from subsidy
says punch the f out of kevin
[Music]
shame on you tim
shame on you
charizard i choose you
like any decent self-respecting weeb of
millennial antecedents
tim is an avid lover of pokemon pokemon
was i mean honestly if i'm completely
honest with you
one of the first animes i ever
technically watched and i didn't really
realize i was watching an anime that is
gen one what
mole trace is gen one
oh bro i'm shocked i don't know anything
outside of one i don't know anything
else out of one listen
listen i'll i'll admit i i wish i knew
more about pokemon okay so maybe he's
not like a die hard but he certainly
likes pokemon from reminiscing about the
original gameboy games to opening up
about his pokemon go addiction to
opening card packs live for his audience
pokemon has made a surprising number of
appearances on tim's stream but there
was one poll in particular that really
made headlines
[Music]
oh my god
that
no way
[Music]
that's it
that's it right let's go dude
oh my gosh
that's right in february of 2020 tim
opened the all too coveted shiny
charizard gx the rarest card in the
hidden fate set live on stream in front
of 20 000 viewers
i can't believe it
i can't believe it i can't believe it
dude
oh thank goodness i didn't drop this one
man
the card is valued at 200 by collectors
which might be pocket change for a guy
who drives a lambo but it isn't about
the money it's about the pride of
executing such a god-tier pull on stream
and of course
it's about the content
shiny
charizard
gx
unbelievable we unpacked it
opened it hold it pulled it that's the
term
egghead
it's no secret that despite being a
pretty sweet guy tim has endured
countless jabs and jokes about his
physical appearance
you look like a troll doll pencil topper
that was stung by a bee
you look like shrek if shrek decided to
bleach his body
thank you
you look like the kind of snowman my son
makes out of mixed up colors of play-doh
how do you even like how do you think of
this i want you to know i wrote all this
[__] myself too
but of all the corporal parodies to
which the tatman has been subjected
none are as prolific as the egging he's
faced around the resemblance he bears to
well
an egg
just hanging out huh yeah
now it turns into a thing like which one
is my head since bidding farewell to his
flowing locks tim has been habitually
likened to a walking talking poultry pod
ginger green
whips bro
you're starting to get out of pocket
with some of these edits all right
[Music]
this dude symphony gets eight kills bro
everyone's like pepe left dude eight
kills dude
i can't side note huskers i don't know
how we got out of that situation bro
[Music]
the best part about tim going bald
though was that it led him to make a
startling discovery wait a minute
wait a minute is there a dent in my head
hold on
hold on a minute i can't win i literally
can't win i'm balding at the age of 25 i
started balding and now
i have a dent in my head
tim in good humor began incorporating
his dent into his brand but his shocking
discovery led others to making
stupefying ones of their own
[Music]
i always told him i always told him i
got a better bald head than him and he
always said no
[Music]
and the truth will set you free chap
alright everyone that wraps up our
expedition of the tim iceberg was there
anything that stood out to you perhaps
the abuse of an innocent stuffed penguin
or something that you think we missed
like saving kevin from tim
somehow
let us know in the comments below and
we'll see you next time
yeah yeah oh it was danny huh okay i was
wondering who i was wondering who left
this british flag in this in the sub
dude i was like i don't know i don't
know why this is in here i must maybe i
had a crazy bender the other night set
sail for uh you know set sail for the
for the coast of the united kingdom but
no man i guess he just left it in here i
don't know why it's in here but